m
[Musique]
alors on est dans la maison de la flamme
est aujourd'hui
on va faire le quasiment les premières
images du premier épisode avec le
présentateur qui va à nous c'est le jeu
et moi qui arrive pour la première fois
dans la vraie vie un homme qui mettrait
en compétition une quinzaine de femmes
les unes contre les autres seraient
considérés comme un immonde port
dégueulasse mais ici ça n'est pas la
vraie vie s'appelle le présentateur son
prénom c'est le présentateur et son nom
c'est de la femme enfant
oui c'était pas bien je me faire mieux
ok ça marche et quand on lance le
mouvement il commence son texte je suis
ok la corse est bien d'accord tanguay
moi tant que ça c'est un mélange de
cyril féraud qui fait les jeux sur
france 3 le président de stéphane
rotenberg de delahousse un peu pour pour
les cheveux de stéphane bern pour
l'élégance et d'yves mourousi dans la
vraie vie un homme qui mettrait en
compétition une quinzaine de femmes les
unes contre les autres ce serait
considéré comme un immonde port
dégueulasse mais ici ça n'est pas la
vraie vie bienvenue dans la flamme
vincent c'est un des derniers qu'on a vu
en castille on a vu plein de gens il a
fait sa première prise
on servira d'ailleurs j'attends celui
laissé aux demoiselles ce soir vous le
savez 9 d'entre vous vont devoir quitter
l'aventuré
une une une d'entre vous va devoir
quitter l'aventuré
hanover d'où la fin donc de prix mais
qu'il a confondu les heures et les et
les gens moi je me suis préparé pour
seront là parce qu'en fait j'ai
tellement
assimiler mois ces trucs-là sais pas
pourquoi je sais que je sais le faire
depuis longtemps
[Rires]
incroyable très heureux très heureux de
vous accueillir ici est très très
heureux de vous présenter votre nouvelle
demeure
non c'est pas vrai
c'est
lorsque pas vrai vous m'offrez la maison
absolument on attend les vins sont ces
deux génies des mots ces requins vincent
qu'un truc beaucoup plus littéraire
poétique non marc marquez avait bien
compris qu'on ne vous offrait pas
véritablement la maison et joe qui a
vraiment un truc d'un peu
d'improvisation de vannes etc il y avait
une espèce de deux personnes qui
essaient de danse est une espèce de 2
valent ce que tu dis que vous tournez
voiture le sco la vie est une aventure
et d'une fluidité folle entre lui et moi
ça a toujours été comme ça et ça ne
s'explique pas dit que la vie aussi est
une émission vous dis pas ça personne ne
dise a sonné sa marque dans quelques
instants
treize candidates vont faire leur
apparition et c'est exactement ce dont
on avait besoin pour le tournage ou
fluidité comme ça dans le jeu c'est ça
vaut ça vaut des millions à l'heure où
je vous parle
oui est ce que vous savez qui vous à les
éliminer je pense qu'il est un peu trop
tôt pour faire un choix d'accord mais
mon choix est fait a donc vous avez
choisi oui oui mais je pense qu'il est
encore un peu trop tôt pour faire un
choix maintenant si votre décision est
prise c'est qu'il n'est pas trop tôt
pour faire un toit à mort ma décision
est prise là j'aurais même noter sur ce
papier n'a comme et pour le coup je
pense qu'il est encore un peu tôt pour
faire chaud